Hey,
what's going on is bill burn his time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday,
February 29th,
2016 happy late.
Yay.
Oh happy leap year and happy birthday to the poor said clients who only have a
birthday once every four years,
you know.
Good Lord.
Can you imagine going on that first day with that broad pitch in about that?
And I always feel love tone.
It was like everybody yells at a birthday every single year.
It was like,
oh zero.
Then I was four then it was a,
you know,
she'd be in good shape.
Dog
Eating fucking 75% less birth gate.
Birthday cake every year.
Right now I'll wait.
And how does that math work out?
If in four years you had four slices of cake,
all right,
but you appointed a leap year,
you only had one.
Yeah,
that percentage doesn't work cause you know you have one.
Somebody else says too,
they got 100% more than you got,
right?
They provided their equals slices.
Now Jason's pill,
you're gonna if you're gonna break out fractions,
I think of Gunnar still a little birthday cake.
Fractions.
All right,
so then they're getting fucking 300% more cake than you are,
man.
I Bay,
you know something.
I've been,
anybody's born on February 29th is either a miserable con or just one of the
coolest laid back people like,
you know,
oh my God,
another birthday.
I think years flying by now.
Now they're not actually,
to be honest with you,
that's kind of weird.
So like when the fuck are you actually like,
okay,
like say when you're 29 you know that doesn't work.
Do your 28 it's gotta be forced,
right?
Wait,
your zero Jesus Christ is,
it'd be fucking annoying.
Zero if you had a baby born on the 29th grade year is zero the first year.
All right.
One,
two,
three now four be back again to four right?
I don't fucking know.
All I know is it somebody's birthday today and it hasn't been their birthday
since 2012 so happy fucking birthday.
What does that work out?
16 1514 1312 would be five years.
I can't fucking do it.
I don't know when it was once every three years,
cheeses,
anything that happens every four years usually sucks people's birthdays on leap
year,
World Cup soccer,
the Olympics,
you know,
actually like Olympic hockey,
but then I hate all this fucking Douche is who never watched hockey.
And they'd be like,
see if it was like this,
I would watch it all the time.
What?
Only two weeks long with no fighting.
You fucking do shit beat.
Nobody cares whether you watch it and not least.
I know.
At least I don't.
So,
um,
anyways,
I apologize for the,
uh,
you know what?
I don't apologize.
Oh,
I okay.
I will,
I will.
I'll apologize for the being this late.
I was going to do it on Sunday when I was up in Foxwoods.
Joe,
this go to the fucking casino while in the middle of words,
Yo,
um,
I was going to record on Sunday,
but a verse,
he got some tickets to see the Yukon,
a Houston cougars game up,
uh,
you know,
big fucking program by the way,
man.
How about the fight?
You know,
very quietly.
I probably shouldn't say very quietly.
I just don't pay attention to the sports ladies hopes.
You know,
I knew that fucking,
uh,
Tennessee with pat summit,
right.
Was fucking crushing it.
And I know Yukon was,
I thought they were doing all right,
but I thought it was mainly fucking pat summit.
And then I went to the Goddamn Yukon game.
I got a picture of it here on my phone.
You know,
somebody sent me a picture of a,
of a hairless pit bull that had freckles.
It's the most adorable thing ever seen in your life,
but the person said it looked like
maybe,
ah,
I like a good tweet.
You know,
I don't get,
I don't give a shit if you break my balls,
if it makes me laugh.
All right,
so the fucking lady,
the lady huskies.
Well,
let's do it in order here.
Let's do the guys first.
Considering they have way less.
You know,
you always want to build towards your closing bit.
All right,
the guys,
the fellows have won four national championships since 1999.
All right.
The Yukon men's huskies have one 1999 2004 2011 2014 that's very fucking
respectables.
Anybody want more than that?
I don't know.
I'm not going to look it up.
Kentucky or Duke,
I would guess.
Maybe not Duke.
Right dough.
Dough.
All right.
Um,
but the ladies,
they want it.
95.
Okay.
They want it in 2000 2002 2003 2004 2009 and then the fucking Goddamn poor
excuse for speakers hanging from that fucking building that they have what it
through the ceilings.
Peeling is in the way.
The next two banners,
they want it 2014 2015 now I got to fucking look it up.
Well,
as far as what I can see here on the phone,
that's one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight.
Yeah.
And there's two other banners behind that that's gotta be a championship won.
National Champions.
What an asshole.
What a fuck did I walk down and take it correctly?
I'll maybe look it up before I did this.
Yeah.
All right.
Hang on a second.
Hang on.
Oh,
Jesus.
Now I'm typing on my phone.
This is going to take for fucking ever,
I looked a lot the most random women's huskies.
Why would I write that?
That's not going to get me there.
Okay.
Yukon.
Huskies,
chair P and ships.
All right,
give me the lady skew it.
The lady's going to come up first.
Uh,
the men's do you sexist motherfuckers national championships.
You fucking go.
Hang on ladies ladies.
Okay,
here we go.
Connecticut women's basketball.
I apologize.
I even know if I had an had any fucking decency,
I would edit most of the south,
but I'm not gonna.
All right.
National Tournament Championship as Ebidta Conference Championships.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Nobody cares about any of this.
Elite eight final four tournament champions.
95 2000 2002 2003 2004 2009 2010 2013 2014 2015 one,
two,
three,
four,
five.
They wanted five or less.
Six fucking years.
And since the year 2000 number that corner a bit.
They wanted one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine fucking times total domination.
Fuck a dog snoring.
You know my dog's getting fat.
I don't know what's going on with him.
He's changed his food.
We started getting her an extra can cause she's always fucking come on over
licking the bowl there.
You know we felt bad for now.
You should see it.
She looks like a fucking stake worker,
right?
Tennessee lady.
Okay.
Falls.
All right,
here we go.
Come on Wikipedia.
Where the fuck are you
lady Vol?
What'd,
what'd he say?
W what do you think is we think of as more,
Huh?
I get to go with Connecticut at that point.
I though this might be the most boring podcast ever.
Why?
What do you do?
You get what you pay for.
All right,
fuck it.
I'm not looking it up at a mama eyes.
A,
C and C,
a double here.
I'm very impressed with both of them.
Man.
They're quietly crushed and it's a nice small campus.
They play in this little ass building with,
with Shit Pailin from the ceiling.
The student section was hilarious.
You know when they introduced the other team,
they sit there reading the newspaper.
I thought that was funny.
Now I'm sure somebody's gonna say,
well al Qaeda oil,
corn fucking university used to do that.
I don't give a shit.
It's the first time I saw it.
It was fighting and me,
um,
do,
there was a guy sitting behind is like classic New England Sports Fan.
I never heard a guy like eat anytime the ball didn't go in for the huskies.
He fought,
he had a reason every fucking time down the court.
And this is what killed me.
So I'm like,
all right,
this guy's a total who pad.
Right?
And I turned around and he has on a red sox hat and tee shirt until he's
basically a sports maniac.
Right?
The guy missed his shot.
He'd be like,
Eh,
I didn't follow through.
Next time they come down the court and the big guy,
the guy,
you should have been rotating around these.
The second day I had to double.
Kb should been rotating around.
Next time down the court,
somebody slips.
It was it,
what does it something wrong with the floor.
And I just kept nudging Farsi.
He would,
he would go on like,
like,
like the fucking lady huskies here.
He would go on like four,
five,
four or five runs there,
except instead of winning championships,
he'd be like,
bitch moaning and complaining.
And at one point he made a point,
you know,
they threw it to their big goof there and the guy fucking missed the ball.
And,
uh,
the guy goes,
you know,
if he had a pair of hands,
he would've had to there in verse.
He turned around and goes,
you know what,
you're right.
And the guy just looked at him with like an angry look like he was,
he was so pissed that Yukon was losing.
And we actually,
uh,
you know,
I know they're only having a mediocre year this year.
I mean,
he can't fucking win it every year.
But,
um,
you could sense when you were in there the level,
how seriously everybody was taking it.
Because first he kept saying like,
wow,
these people take this shit really seriously here.
And I just kept pointing up to all the banners.
I'm like,
uh,
I would say at this point that kind of used to winning.
So I guess they are having a disappointing year,
I guess.
I have no idea.
I didn't look it up.
I just started talking about it.
It's what I did.
But that's why the podcast,
um,
was not ready.
Um,
I had a great time up at Foxwoods resort casino is,
by the way,
I want to thank them for having me.
It was their 24th anniversary.
Right.
So they say to me,
um,
before I get there,
they said,
is there any way before your first show if you could come down,
um,
there's a big dinner or something we'd love if you could meet the,
uh,
the tribal council and just stop by and say,
hello.
Right.
These are my employers for the weekend.
What am I going to say?
No.
So I'm like,
absolutely.
I want to meet these native Americans that fucking beat the white man,
you know,
and got their own fucking casino,
right.
So I go down there and I just thought it was going to swing by a table and say
hello to somebody,
thank them for the Gig.
And next thing you know they got this whole,
this is like fucking eyes wide shut fucking dinner going on,
you know the shining kind of shit in the bowels of the casino.
There's some band and there's a stage and is like this Guy Smiley looking
fucking political guy on stage and next thing you know he's,
he's given me an intro.
I had no fucking idea I was going on.
I have no idea what these people are.
And furthermore,
these people had no idea who I was and I just walk on and they go play up.
We've got a local funny man he had this weekend.
Please welcome comedian bill burn.
I was standing there go,
is he bringing me up?
See,
forgive me up and I just fucking walk on stage.
I take the mic and I was like,
I'm looking out at all these old people and shit and it just staring at me.
I was like,
ah,
the Cardia I had no idea.
I was uh,
I was going to be brought up here,
but um,
you know,
congratulations on 24 years.
I'm sure most of you people here know who the next four presidents are going to
be on behalf of regular people.
If you could do something about the population problem.
I really appreciate it and all of this shit is getting nothing.
Right.
I just started talking to them like they were running the world and to just
looking at me like I got fucking 10 heads and I just said,
I just sort of petered out and I went in and uh,
onward and upward.
I just handed it back,
the Guy Smiley and there was just like a little of applause and I just walked
back into the hall with the promoters will walk away.
I was like,
what the,
what the fuck was that?
And he's like,
oh,
I don't know.
That's how he talks.
[inaudible] I didn't know what to watch over our doctorate.
Your Orca.
I weren't talking to Dan.
A pressure natural guardians showing how long hours are terrible,
you know,
nobody knows anything.
Right.
And they just fucking wheel year round.
Um,
yeah.
And then we just fucking,
I think we got on a golf cart at that point.
We,
no,
no.
When we walked through the halls and then they walk me by the crowd that was
going into my show.
So I looked like a complete jerk off I fucking,
I love seeing people after the show.
I fucking hate seeing people before the show.
I don't know why.
I don't know if it's a superstition.
It's just weird to me to be,
for me to just be walking by like the first time you see me,
I'm just walking down the fucking hall.
Oh,
there's that jerk off.
And then you just start looking at why did I pay to see that look at them.
But anyways,
we had a,
um,
we had a great fucking time and a bunch of family and friends coming out,
people I hadn't seen in years.
Do you don't mind.
My first best friend
and then I ever had in life actually came up to the Gig and um,
I hadn't seen him in 36 years.
And,
um,
I was actually thinking the last time I saw him,
you know,
the reason why my family,
we moved away from the town that we had lived in.
And um,
I just remember we were both,
how fucking old was I?
I think we were like seven or eight and you don't know how to say goodbye.
You know,
I probably had been friends with the kids since I was like four.
So basically half my life I was friends with this kid,
so we had loaded up the moving van the last time like we would do in the u haul
thing,
you know,
we'll do it ourselves.
And we just made like 900 fucking trips in this thing.
And um,
we were loading it up for the last time.
And uh,
he lived across the street from me.
So I walked down my driveway and he was out there and he knew this.
He knew it was in,
I knew it was it.
And we were just too young.
Didn't know.
Yes.
You know what to say.
It's seven.
So some kid rode by and I had just written by an a bike and I remember he just
said something to me like,
Oh yeah,
that kid was trying to say that blah blah blah blah.
I couldn't remember anything.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
okay.
I was like,
oh all.
And he just started to walk away and I walked away in the other direction and
then we both looked over our shoulder at the same time and then that was it.
I got in the fucking u haul
and that was it.
I think I came back to the neighborhood like four years later.
I saw him one other time.
So yeah,
1980.
Yes.
Cause I left in [inaudible] 76 some and 80 and then I hadn't seen him since
then.
So,
uh,
we got caught up talking about the old fucking times.
Man.
We didn't even get into it either.
Jesus Christ,
some of the shit we used to do,
you know,
we used to play with fucking matches.
That's what she used to do back then when there was like,
like playing with matches was like,
I dunno,
like having a game boy or whatever these fucking kids do nowadays.
And His dad had these things for,
they will called a monkey matches.
There was just a book of matches and for some reason that they,
it just had a picture of a monkey like wearing like a hat.
Like,
like that was like high brow humor back then,
like dress and monkeys up like human beings,
you know.
And also having pictures of dogs playing poker and Shit,
passing cards underneath the table with their paws and shit,
you know.
So his dad,
for whatever reason,
I always had these match books that had pictures of monkeys that were like,
you know,
dress like dentists,
like lab coats on and shit or just some stupid fucking hat,
you know.
And uh,
so we would,
this is what we would do.
We would go over and we would like basically underneath the tree we would bunch
up a bunch of pine needles and you would just light it on fire and just look at
the fire and then try and put it out.
And um,
you know,
sometimes you put it out,
sometimes you didn't.
Sometimes a neighbor would come running over Christ.
What the fuck are you kids though?
Yo Dahlia.
And um,
I did that one time.
I lit it and all of a sudden it just got completely out of control.
And this guy came running over the giant trashcan.
They had filled up with water,
thank fucking Christ and um,
and then somebody else in the neighborhood,
I remember fucking lit it on fire,
lit the whole fucking woods on fire.
And uh,
I know,
I know it was two because he wrote down to the fire station and,
and said that he didn't do it,
but he knows that he knew that my friend did it and he fucking rat it out.
My friend and I'm sure the fire department was looking at the kid looking at him
like,
listen,
you little rat,
we know you fucking did it.
Right.
Um,
so what,
I was cool to see him and um,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about it.
I,
I hate doing this thing after I've been on a fucking plane,
you know.
Oh,
you know,
I watched on the plane for the second time,
I saw the movie a black mask,
you know,
I know that that kind of got mixed reviews.
That's one of those movies.
You got to see it more than once.
See it the second time to Johnny Depp is fucking unbelievable in that movie.
He's unfucking believable.
And um,
there's a couple of other actors here.
I've got to get their fucking names.
They were absolutely amazing,
but,
uh,
I liked it the first time.
I loved it the second time I saw it.
So,
um,
you know,
I know,
but most people I heard from a,
from Massachusetts to like,
dude,
the fucking ax as you just shut the fuck up.
You know,
when I went to Fargo,
they were bitching about the fucking accents and Fargo,
does that mean Fargo's a bad movie?
Well,
why don't,
why don't we hire you,
who's not an actor,
will have you fucking do it and we'll see how that works out.
But,
um,
I just felt,
you know,
the second time when I saw it,
like the pacing of it,
I felt like it,
they tied it in to like the absolute sociopath main character that they would
try.
You are so fucked up as I'm nervous about talking about it.
That's the level of power that those fucking guys had.
Um,
it reminded me of the Shawshank redemption where a lot of people,
I know the first time they saw they didn't like that movie because they felt it
was so long.
It was dragging on and on and on and on.
But um,
okay.
My,
my theory on that movie was they were giving you the sense of what it was like
to do time where it becomes like this open ended thing.
No beginning,
no middle,
no end.
It's actually,
sounds like I'm shitting on the movie,
but it's just the way it would fade down and then just fade up and every time in
the crowd you'd like to be anticipating that there'd be this major turn and it
was just another day in prison.
A few years later.
Um,
I kind of felt like they were trying to do that with the Whitey Bulger character
where,
um,
you know,
they was saying like he was a sociopath,
like they,
and how he slowly drew in the FBI guys to the point that they were entangled in
his bullshit.
Um,
any insulated himself that way.
I really,
I dunno.
Maybe I was too dumb to get all of that shit the first time,
but the second time I watched it,
like I said,
I went from liking that movie to fucking loving that movie.
So,
um,
whatever.
Give it a shot if you haven't,
but I'm speaking of which the fucking Os Guinness well,
last night.
Huh?
White guys fucking crushing it.
Ah,
we fucking sweet.
Cleaned up last night.
I'm just fucking with you man.
That was a,
uh,
I only got to see,
I got to see Chris Rock's opening monologue,
which I thought was great.
I thought he handled the whole thing fucking perfectly.
MMM.
And uh,
what else did I see?
I didn't see a lot cause right is it started?
The show was starting.
I think we had a nine o'clock shown.
Started little bit after eight.
But,
um,
I have no idea who won what.
I know the Boston movie about the fucking pedophile priests.
I heard that,
that thing one.
MMM.
That was it.
Nobody fell down.
Nothing else happened,
right.
Is that it?
Oh,
very quietly.
The first,
uh,
Asian director,
I believe ever fucking once something is that what I saw?
I don't know.
This is,
you know,
just a reoccurring thing.
I'm not going to look anything up.
I'm just going to start talking about it and uh,
you know,
that's going to be it.
Okay.
You know what I don't understand.
Like I don't understand the weight that people put on the fucking Oscar.
So I really got to tell you that though.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
I just don't,
I don't fucking get it.
I was joking this weekend,
like just sitting there watching a bunch of adults running around wanting to win
a trophy.
It's like,
what?
What are you fucking little league
trophy is if a kid's aren't they,
you have ribbons and shit and it makes them feel good and you're taking them out
for a fucking snow cone and then that's it.
Yeah,
he put him to bed.
You get yourself a whiskey and you sit there and just stare at the wall and
that's basically your life.
I mean,
why would he do old?
Are you,
you need a fucking trophy.
Um,
yeah.
I don't,
I don't give a shit about like that type of stuff,
but I definitely think that there should be opportunity for everybody.
You know,
I'd like to hear everybody's stories.
So I had no problem with any of that shit.
But I do just think it's funny that people fucking flip out and start crying
about winning a goddamn trophy in this trophy means more than that trophy.
This one's more prestigious.
Um,
all right,
let's,
I got to do a couple reads here for this week.
What the fuck am I clicking on there?
All right.
Um,
Jesus,
quite trunk club,
everybody,
no matter what time of year it is,
you have got to make every second count.
No,
you don't.
You can chill out.
You know,
you can sit down on a,
on a deck or maybe your neighbor's deck if he's not home,
and just fucking put your feet up and enjoy yourself.
And then what time of year it is,
you got to make every second cap.
It sounds like a workout video.
And that means looking your best.
No more ratty jeans are oversized hoodies.
Recent college graduates.
It's time to upgrade your wardrobe and let trunk club handle all the work for
you.
Trunk Club takes the hassle man out of shopping by finding the best clothes for
you and your style.
You'll look and feel amazing and we'll always have the perfect close for your
season.
Oh my God.
Todd,
I can't believe how good you look.
Sorry.
Uh,
at trunk club.com/burp.
You answer simple questions about your style preferences.
Sties and are assigned an expert stylist.
What do you mean x?
They're working for trunk club.
If they were an expert when they're they own fucking line of clothing.
Your stylus,
we'll handpick clothes from the best premium brands.
Chest approve of what you like and send back what you don't like and just like
that.
A trunk full of fucking cloves alive arrives right on your doorstep.
Filled with handpick clothes that are perfect for you.
Try them on.
Keep what you like.
Yeah,
try him on.
Don't just stare at them out.
You know they'll just look at them stupid.
Keep what you like and easily return what you don't in their prepaid trunk.
Trunk Club is not a subscription service.
You only pay for the clothes you keep from your trunk.
No hidden charges.
Just great clothes.
Get started today at Trunk Club and Trunk Club,
sorry,
will style you for free plus free shipping both ways.
You only pay for the clothes that you keep take to take advantage.
Go to trunk club.com/burr that's trunk club.com/burr trunk club.com/birth all
right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody.
You guys,
evidently according to this copy,
I've figured it out.
Evidentaly I've discovered the key to an amazing shave.
Isn't it so weird that they would write that like,
like I like I would actually say that,
hey guys,
I've figured it out and you'd be like one how not to work and make more money.
No better than that.
I've started.
I discovered the key to an amazing shave.
Sorry.
All right.
You know what?
Why would you have that big of a fucking intro for something that's stupid?
It's just shaving your face.
Okay,
did the reality here is you have,
you get,
you get a good shave for a little amount of money that that's all that's going
on here.
Okay.
We're not curing cancer.
Let's get back to the copy.
It's simple.
That's exactly what dollar shave club.com does and why you could be a proud
member like millions of others.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing razors right to your door for a third of
the price of what those greedy razor corporation cons.
Charge both of your wallet and your face.
Finally,
get some relief.
Joni Dollar Shave club.com means you can afford to shave with a fresh blade
anytime you want,
which feels fantastic and for the smoothest shave ever.
Use their fresh.
Use Your fresh dollar shave club blade with the Ed Doc Dick cabbies easy.
It's not your average shave cream.
It's high quality ingredients to make your skin feels soft,
smooth and moisturized.
Your blade will glide gently across your skin if you want the most amazing shape
possible.
Take it from me.
Use a fresh dollar shave club blade and doctor cabbies.
Easy shave butter.
Two reasons to join dollar shave club.com/bar today.
That's dollar shave club.com/bar and lastly,
but certainly not leastly are old friends,
stamps.com hey everyone your to do list can seem odd to control.
So much to do but so little time.
But there's one thing you could check off your to do list that's going to the
Goddamn motherfucking Cock sock and post office fags to stamps.com with
stamps.com you can buy and print official us postage right from your own
computer or a printer,
stamps.com we'll send you a digital scale,
right beacon,
way your drugs on it and mail something to your grandmother automatically.
It calculates the exact posted you need for any letter or package,
any class of mail,
print the posted you need,
put it on your letter or a package,
and then just hand it to your mail carrier and you're done.
All right,
I use stamps.com anytime I'm selling bullshit after my show and I'm a moron if I
can figure it out.
Well,
God dammit.
So can you,
and if not,
you can find someone that can help you out.
Right now.
Use My last name,
birth for this special law for four week trial plus a ton or $10 bonus offer,
which includes the digital scale and up to $55 free postage.
For Christ's sake,
don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburpburthatstamps.com enter
burr.
All right.
And with that,
it's mercifully over smart.
Softly over.
Um,
all right.
I don't know if you guys know this,
but I guess they're working on cars that are going to drive themselves in the
future.
Um,
I don't know.
I mean,
how fucking lazy people going to get,
it's going to be great for drinking and driving it just be drinking and writing.
You know,
you,
all of a sudden you'll always have that fucking thing,
right?
I don't,
I don't like this man.
I don't like how everything's becoming fucking automated.
You know?
I feel like rich people are gradually phasing us out,
you know,
cause you know God damn well the only reason why they allow us to exist is
because they need us to farm,
right?
They need us to deliver shit.
They need us to do a bunch of shit.
And I guide could add another example.
I don't know.
Dance around like a monkey at a fucking casino.
Come downstairs and say a couple of words that your little fucking Illuminati
party in the basement.
They need us to do that.
But once everything is automated and it just handles it,
it's fucking self.
Okay.
Do you think you could be a part of that group?
What if you are part of a group that was just going to slowly fucking just phase
everybody else out,
you know,
in some hours would happen in your lifetime.
All right Mike,
who would you keep these free Hitler s type questions.
But this is the type of fucking madness that I think everybody's capable of.
You know,
especially,
um,
I don't know if you travel on the road,
some of the dope shit fucking meet out there watching people get stirred up.
You know,
in all honesty,
I can't stand like the choices that we have for president right now,
you know,
is it starts to go towards as a fucking torpedo,
uh,
that fucking Saint Bernard looking guy,
Bernie Sanders,
right?
His jowls,
um,
as a torpedo,
his fucking campaign and all democrats are walking around,
he can't wear it.
He can't win.
I love that.
I love it.
Yeah.
Cause you're too much of a pussy to fucking vote for him.
That's why,
right.
So you're going to vote for this fucking,
this clammy fucking crook or this guy who isn't saying anything,
but like,
I really believe that,
you know,
you can talk people into fucking wiping out everybody on the planet.
He's very easily just listening to Donald Trump,
his speeches where he just says absolutely nothing.
You know,
he said today he was talking to college graduates and he's literally going
right,
like I'm going to bring jobs back to the United States.
You wait,
there's going to be more jobs here by the time I'm done,
it's going to make your head spin.
I'm going to have,
I'm going to have apple bring manufacturing jobs back from China to here.
Okay.
And people clapped.
He never has to say how he's going to do all,
I'm going to plug up the hole in the ozone layer.
Water's going to be clear.
I'm going to get rid of all terrorism and that's going to be the first week
I like this guy.
Sky Makes Sense.
He's making it great again.
No.
And then you got to Hillary out.
She just talks to her fucking teeth.
It's like she,
you know,
she looks like she should be doing like a ventriloquist act,
but the puppet isn't there.
Um,
fucking,
I dunno.
I have no,
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
I no idea.
And I don't even know who the other guys are.
I just heard a couple of them talking and trying to trash Donald Trump and they
just stay.
Sounded pathetic.
Just not good speakers.
This is just a,
this is a bad one is a bad one.
Yeah.
Like,
I bet people watching,
you know you don't,
if you've got a great college program and a bunch of seniors fucking graduate
graduate and you just,
you know,
he just go through a bad four year period.
I think that's what we're coming through.
We're coming out all right now you know like this one guy who was saying he was
going to get rid of Obamacare if he was elected.
And people like applauding,
like I,
I just,
I don't fucking get it.
I don't get why I don't even,
I don't have Obamacare.
I guess my tax dollars paid for it,
but I don't have any problems with somebody.
Like I don't want my fellow countrymen walking around with a fucking too thick.
You need your spleen removed.
Fuck you figure it out for yourself.
Why do we help each other out a little more?
You know,
what can we do that and if full act anybody needs this spleen out
Donald Trump,
I bet I could run.
I could run for president if that's all you gotta do is just say you're going to
do all this awesome shit.
You never fucking do it.
And everyone will have healthcare and it will be free.
All right.
Um,
oh,
this weekend,
by the way,
all these self driving cars,
let's get back to that fucking thing.
So evidentaly some self driving car hit a bus,
which is fucking tremendous for anybody who loves driving.
That is such a tremendous fucking thing that happened today or yesterday or
maybe last year.
All I know is I just found the fucking story.
I'm so fucking site.
It's the self driving car.
Hit the fucking hit the fucking bus.
I mean that even though it was only going like two miles an hour,
it's just so fucking great because it,
it hit a bus.
So all you got to say,
it's just,
you know,
just be like,
well what if,
what if there was a bunch of kids on that bus?
Right?
And then that'll delay it a good 20 fucking years.
Um,
let me see if I can find this story.
Self-Driving Google says it bears some responsibility after self driving car
hits bus.
Can you fucking believe that?
What was there?
Was there a person driving the bus?
I would say that you,
you,
you have all the fucking responsibility.
Unless this guy literally drove into the fucking thing.
Elsa,
Ben Incorporate,
incorporate Google set on Monday.
It bears some responsibility after one of its self driving cars struck municipal
bus in a minor crash earlier this month.
The crash may be the first case of one of it's autumn autonomous cars hitting
another vehicle and the fault of the self driving car.
Okay
Dude,
this is going to be a shit show.
This is just one and it already hit a fucking bus.
You know what I mean?
That's fucking,
that's lunacy.
It's fucking lunacy,
man.
I will tell you it mean I think it will.
It will.
It will cause people to drink like they've never drank before.
I mean
hap most nights I don't drink out here because I,
you know,
I drive myself places,
I don't fucking Uber.
Well that'll put Uber out of business.
Right?
Okay.
Well I guess if you don't have a fucking car,
I dunno.
Don't you guys like driving?
I will.
I'll be have like the option,
my thing is how is the insurance going to work?
Because you know,
God damn well,
there's no way the insurance company is going to take that fucking liability on
it that they're claiming they're going to get rid of.
They'll be no more deaths from car accidents is going to be no more accidents.
It's just going to be,
it's going to be like just accident free.
Okay.
This is amazing to me that this,
that it's gotten this fucking far considering,
you know,
that like the amount of times they tried to kill the electric car,
right?
And you know,
big oil companies,
that type of thing.
I mean,
you're fucking with their,
their blue blood money without having that,
let's go electric cute and elephant to show how fucking dangerous sees cars are.
Right.
So
yeah,
like
does,
the only thing I can think,
what will these insurance companies,
they're making enough money to go down there and whack somebody at ABC Inc.
Right?
You know,
they fucking do shit like that.
And you go to a diner and all of a sudden you stagger outgoing.
They poisoned me and he'd do a face plant,
then your invention disappears.
Oh,
I'm going down the rabbit hole.
This is why I think they're letting this one go through cause they're eventually
going to get rid of all of us.
And when they do that,
they're going to have no more limo drivers.
So they're like,
whoa,
whoa.
We'll do the future is if we were to Raj somewhere,
I'm it,
I'm not going to drive my car and soil my wealthy hoons Elma.
And then somebody is like,
well what if we just had,
we'll just make the cars drive themselves.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Kill them all then,
you know,
slinky,
poisoned them.
Remove them from the balloon it.
Okay.
Um,
I wonder if they got rid of everybody,
how long it would take for this funk,
you know,
to go back to normal,
you have to take all the nuclear waste bright.
Just send it out,
you know,
out of the fucking space.
Right.
Send it towards Mars.
Just make sure you don't hit the moon
and all you do is just fucking chill out nearly a little house.
I want to,
how long it would take to undo all APP,
but you all this shit that people leave behind,
you know,
fucking going to do with all of that.
That's all going to go into the soil.
I take a Louie ain't I wouldn't happen in your lifetime.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
I am all over the place,
man.
What the fuck am I talking about here?
Murdering people and self driving cars.
You should see this fucking car.
By the way,
this fucking self driving car,
it makes the Volkswagen beetle looked like a Goddamn Lamborghini.
Okay.
People on the Simpsons drive a better looking car then that fucking thing.
Oh,
you need all that all going to be the exact same fucking one,
right?
Okay.
You'll have your options of like three different colors,
like white,
black or beige.
Oh Man,
this is not uplifting.
I'll tell you what's up.
Lifting March 5th,
this weekend,
UFC one 96.
Conor Mcgregor,
um,
UFC one 96.
What are they calling this one?
Did they,
do they stop naming them by the way,
to have they come up with 196 adjectives that,
that,
that describe how fucking tremendous said sports that sport is.
You know,
you would have seen 12 the redemption,
the red badge or whatever.
They always had like these cool fucking names up to once you get up to like one
96,
they gotta be running out.
Right.
Let me see what they got here.
Yeah.
UFC One 96.
Conor McGregor versus some Guy Diaz.
I wish I knew these guys named better.
I'm,
you know,
there's only so much shit I can pay attention to.
Um,
these taking on late replacement,
Nate Diaz that Jesus,
what happened?
He was supposed to fight somebody else.
Rafio I'm not going to fucking insulted Latinos by trying to pronounce it,
although I could give you a good laugh here.
Rafael dos Anjos Rafael dos Anjos was from his show down against Connor with a
broken foot or get the fuck.
Do you know what I was reading something on Mcgregor today.
Do you know what?
I don't understand.
I don't.
Somebody in the fight game,
please explain this to me.
That guy walks around at one 70 and he's shredded.
And then before his fight for whatever fucking reason,
he's got to go down to one 45.
Now I can understand if the other guy just walks around at one 45 or maybe one
55 and kind of for whatever reason,
just wants to beat the fuck out of the guy.
So he's willing to starve himself down to one 45 for the love of God.
Can anybody in the fight game that,
that does this,
why can't,
you know
if Carter walks around at one 70 and the other guys walking around at one 65,
why don't they just fight it like one 60?
Why do they got to bring everybody all the way the fuck down there?
I,
I just don't understand why they got to do that shit.
Um,
check out the sports illustrated article on,
uh,
on Conor McGregor.
They got like this whole thing where the only briefly talk about it,
but they're talking about cutting weight.
And it actually sounds in a lot of ways worse than the fight,
like talking about the pain and the agony of it and it's,
I,
I can't even a,
I'm not going to be able to do it justice because I just read it.
I have a very poor memory and I've never gone through it.
But,
uh,
Holly Holmes also fighting against,
we should tape and uh,
I'm taking a night off from stand up and I'm going to fucking hang.
You know what's great,
this is the one sport that I can really watch my wife like,
she likes going to live hoop too,
but she loves the fucking UFC.
She gets into it like at a crazy level.
Like that time when he,
that guy kicked,
kicked the other dude and he had the compound fracture,
you know,
and his fucking leg bent all the way back.
I was just like,
I walked out,
I'm like,
I done done.
I can't watch that.
She,
she was rewinding it,
wanting to watch it again and was like,
like literally interested in it.
Um,
which means she either should have been a serial killer or gotten into the
medical field because if you can fucking stomach that,
um,
either way I can,
I'm,
I'm really excited to see this shit this weekend.
I like it.
Even if they're quick fights,
even if it's a bad thing,
does it make you at least want to work out?
You see those guys and fucking women getting in and they're all fucking jacked.
You look at down at yourself,
usually finishing off a pizza and like,
what the fuck am I doing going down to home depot tomorrow I'm getting a sledge
hammer and a big fucking tire,
you know,
and you know what?
You'd do it for a couple of days and then you quit.
And that's why you're not a champion.
Like what you're going to see on fucking Saturday.
There you go.
There's my promo for the UFC.
Um,
all right,
let's,
uh,
let's read some fucking letters for this week.
Shall We?
Everybody,
chances are the close of Cleo.
You're losing your finger sweetheart.
Glad you didn't walk the red carpet at the,
at the fucking Oscars.
They would have been all over you.
All right.
Leaving the country.
If Trump wins,
dear Billy elect,
what's your take on people who say they're going to leave the country if Trump
wins?
Uh,
besides the potential for lanes to open up on the highway.
I just hope the people that say they're going to leave leave,
so I don't have to point out who's a lying sack of shit.
Um,
there are obviously joking,
no one's going to lead this country,
but,
uh,
it's just,
you know,
he's a very extreme guy.
You know,
I think people said that when Obama,
they definitely said it during George Bush with some famous star set and I
remember,
I thought it was like funny.
Then of course Fox News,
it was lunch or league.
Why don't you get the fuck Outta here?
You're like fucking lunacy.
Um,
what do I think about people say that?
I think it's kind of Hacky at this point.
I think that's what everybody says.
When there's somebody that's on the fringe on one side or the other,
somebody always ends up going to [inaudible] fucker wins are going to leave.
Where are you going to go?
This is what people forget when you,
uh,
when you leave this country,
you,
you immediately become an immigrant who's taking somebody else's job in the
country that you're going to and you get treated as such.
You know,
even if you white,
they don't want,
but they don't want Americans moving up to Canada,
fucking with their population,
taking their jobs.
You know,
all of a sudden you're standing this driving a spike into a tree to take out
some maple syrup instead of the other guy.
They don't want that.
I don't want that at all.
Um,
all right.
Yeah,
I just think that just the same,
I mean,
it's fucking scary.
it's both scary.
I think Hillary's a fucking lying sack of shit.
Totally dishonest.
And I think Donald Trump is a reality show star.
Okay.
That's the best we can fucking dope.
I just don't fucking get it.
It keeps getting worse.
Jesus fucking,
the last guy,
the last guy that I thought was decent was the first George Bush,
you know?
Yeah.
I like Bonnie went into Kuwait and then like,
he keeps it all right.
That's enough.
He didn't go all fucking nuts and we got the fuck out of there,
you know,
and then fucking Clinton came in.
I don't what the fuck that was a big frat party where he's getting his dick
shocked.
He's lying about shit.
People got stuff on them mysteriously die.
I mean,
it was fucking nuts.
Then he bombed some people to get out of a fucking blow job accusation.
They'll whole fucking thing was,
I don't know.
It's been crazy ever since.
Um,
I don't know shit about politics.
Don't listen to me.
All right.
Boyfriends,
smoking habit.
Hey Mister burr.
Love the podcast and the stand up.
Come to Rochester,
New York soon.
Uh,
I would love all,
you know what,
you know,
what is a buffalo date and as Syracuse date in the works.
Yes ma'am.
Yes sir.
Whatever.
Wherever this is writing the shit.
Um,
uh,
with the f I just scrolled down.
Sorry.
Love the podcasts and the standup.
Come to Rochester,
New York.
How would appreciate some advice from yourself and the lovely Nia if she's
available.
Uh,
she ain't here today,
man.
All right.
I've been with my boyfriend for almost two years and since day one,
I knew of his daily weed smoking habit.
He doesn't let her let it hinder his life.
Still very social,
faithful,
going to,
going to work every day.
Uh,
he scheduled,
he eats healthy and he goes to the gym four to five days a week.
I tried getting used to it,
um,
since it's something that he does and it,
and it isn't a problem in his life,
but I've never wanted to try drugs or alcohol.
So I don't know what the feeling of being under the influence of something as
like now because not because of that.
My problem is unless I see him during the day,
and even then it'll take a hit.
He's not sober.
Is it wrong of me to be concerned that whenever he sees me,
he's under the influence of something?
Uh,
whenever we go to the movies or a comedy show,
he'll bring half a cookie so we can enjoy the show more.
And why don't I want him to relax after work by vaping a bag and hanging out
with me.
Considering this habit has,
it hasn't hindered his life in any way?
Do I have a reason to be uneasy about this?
I understand why he does it and he tells me it doesn't affect his feeling about
feelings about me and about us being together.
But it still makes me uneasy whenever I know he's high.
MMM.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean if you don't like it,
you don't like it.
And if he enjoys it,
he enjoys it.
So you both know where you stand.
MMM.
I gotta be honest.
I mean,
if someone was drinking every day,
they would be probably an issue with that.
Although there's no medicinal purposes for,
uh,
alcohol is there,
unless they've taken an arrow out of your back.
Don't think like rub some on your gums or some shit.
I can't remember how it goes.
You take a shot.
Is that what it is?
You bite down on a fucking garden hose?
I don't remember.
MMM.
Yeah.
I mean,
if he's getting fucking begged all the time and he always,
you know,
so he'll enjoy it more.
Yeah.
That's a little bit of a red flag.
I,
you know,
honestly if you fucking doing it every day and you never really sober and he
just sort of constantly just sorta hi.
Um,
that's probably not a good way to go through life,
but it is his choice.
I would just tell him,
just be like,
look,
I'm not saying you can't smoke,
but like if you're high all the time and I'm sober,
so I'm constantly talking to a buzzed you and um,
it bothers me.
Okay.
I would just tell him that and I think that it's going to bother him because
when you fucking smoke weed like that,
it's a religion,
you know what I mean?
It's not like,
you know,
every day he comes home and he does this one little thing,
puts his shoes in the wrong spot or some shit.
This is like you're talking about his state of consciousness when he's around
you at all fucking times.
Basically you want them to alter that.
So that's a kind of a major change.
MMM.
You didn't tell me how old he was,
but,
um,
I dunno,
I don't know much about weed.
I know some people say they get productive when,
when they're,
when they're using it and that type of stuff,
but,
uh,
I dunno,
I really feel that,
you know,
and this is somebody who's like,
realize that his drinking is out of control again.
So I just sort of stopped for the last fucking three days.
Okay.
MMM.
I mean,
I really have to watch it with myself.
Okay.
Because I have the kind of job where,
you know,
I can get fucked up every night basically,
and then sleep in the next day.
Now granted,
my career would suffer and I wouldn't get anywhere and eventually,
you know,
but I mean,
I could do some before,
like I might career totally did a fucking nose dive provided I didn't like,
you know,
do something stupid like fucking,
get behind the wheel of a car,
fucking assault somebody.
If I was just getting drunk every day,
um,
yeah,
that would affect where I was in the business.
But it'd be like a long seven year,
like tapering off,
you know,
back to doing the comedy vault at Remington's in Boston,
which doesn't exist anymore.
But
MMM.
You know,
I,
I don't know.
I just personally,
I know I really got to watch it and my,
my,
my thing about people who smoke weed is the fact that they can be on it and
nobody really knows,
like,
you know,
and one,
they high all the time,
they're experienced being high and they can just go to work being high and,
uh,
you can't do that drunk.
He can't go to work like,
you know,
shotgun a beer and walk in.
People just know it just doesn't work.
Um,
but I'm not exactly 100% exactly against it the way I used to in the early days
of this podcast when I didn't know a lot about it.
Now I'm understanding that there's certain people,
you know,
if they have really active minds,
I need to fucking chill out.
It's actually a great thing,
um,
for them.
But I,
I really think if you're doing it all the fucking time like that,
yeah.
Like,
this is probably cause for an issue there,
you know,
to bring it up like,
hey,
you kind of fucking basically wasted every time I talk to you.
And then also,
you know,
that whole thing,
he brings half a cookie so he can enjoy the show.
It's like you can't enjoy it sober.
Like those are kind of some,
um,
red flags.
I Dunno.
And I also think that you can get addicted to that shit.
You know,
I think you're,
I think a guy is,
to be honest with you,
people always say Nah,
you're not really addicted to it.
Oh yeah.
You just do it every waking moment.
You can't fucking enjoy something unless you're under the influence of it.
There's something there.
It's just because it's such a mellow thing and it's not like a,
you know,
I got a bug in a buddy of mine from back in the day.
Dude,
he's completely fucking addicted to that shit.
He says I love weed cause it,
it turns my life into a movie.
And um,
no,
he's basically been high since we were sophomores in high school.
Uh Huh.
Without a doubt.
It's fucked with his memory.
It's,
it's fucked with his drive,
you know,
I dunno,
but I understand wanting to get fucked up every day.
Personally.
It's fun.
I think it was weird.
So easy.
A couple of puffs in.
Then boom,
you're there,
you know,
drink.
It takes it off.
I've got to stop talking about this or I'm going to have a drink.
I'd set up to take a week off here,
so.
All right,
well good luck with that.
I would just,
I would just say how you're feeling and if he gives,
you know,
gives you shit back.
I just be like,
look,
give me,
and I'm not being an asshole here.
You just like,
yeah,
high every day.
Can you just like,
not be high a couple of days a week,
but like how do you do that and not feel like you're infringing on this guy's
fucking lifestyle?
I mean,
it's,
I dunno,
I would bring it up to him.
As I said 20 minutes ago before I meandered my way through that.
Sorry about that.
Alright,
I fucked up.
Please advise.
Dear Billy ginger cakes.
I am a 26 year old fucking lazy.
Yeah.
Who's a tremendous fan of your work and all its glorious forms.
Well,
thank you very much.
Uh,
that seen in efforts for family with the dad balls when bill is stuck under the
bed is the funniest fucking thing I've ever seen.
Brilliant.
Well thank you.
I appreciate that.
Um,
I did,
I did something really thin,
all capitals,
really dumb and I would greatly appreciate your insight because I know you will
tell me the ever elusive truth.
I won't tell you why.
I'll tell you what I think is the truth,
whether it's the right answer.
You got it.
You're going to decide that for yourself.
I had been friends with this guy for about two years and now you're fucked him
in your ruin the friendship.
That's what I'm about.
So that's what I'm guessing here.
We met through a larger group of friends.
There was chemistry between us immediately.
This guy is Sophie's married.
Trying to see where,
how,
how this can go off the rails.
This are,
this is reading in the beginning,
like one of those dating sites,
you know they play that stupid piano.
Udub,
but dude do that stupid.
Ooh,
dumb Schiff
and see area killer.
There's could be a sex offender.
I don't know.
No.
Ah,
Metro,
larger group of friends.
There was chemistry between us immediately.
This guy is so funny and so smart and fun to be around.
The problem is he has to penis.
I'm kidding.
She didn't write that.
But he's also a complete and total whore.
Oh Jesus.
Crushing it and good for him,
but exactly the wrong guy to get hung up on.
I knew I liked him too much.
I couldn't help it,
but I thought I could handle being frank.
Some friends with him and eventually eventually the feelings would pass.
Nah,
you can't be around guys like that.
This guy is a pussy getting son of a bitch.
Right.
Dracula would be like,
God damn it.
That guy's got game right.
And by all the,
all the ladies loved Dracula.
He'd come up and start non on their fucking necks and that was it.
Turn them into lady bats.
Right.
Then he kicked him to the curb,
cut himself another chick the next day.
Um,
we started hanging out a lot,
at least two or three nights a week.
Sometimes he said things that made me think maybe he liked me too.
Then on my birthday we got drunk and had sex called it.
Oh,
Jesus.
She says,
let me be clear.
He started it.
I just didn't stop it,
even though I knew it was a bad idea,
so I'm like a little kid.
He started it.
Um,
the worst part is when I woke up the next morning in his bed,
in his bed,
he was gone.
Oh Man.
He fled the fucking seen bill,
the dude shaped hole in the door.
What told me that he was freaked out.
The dude's shaped hole in the door.
He mean,
he was like,
lily ran through the door.
I think you left words out or I'm too fucking old to understand.
Is that some new slang?
Uh,
told me it was too freaked out and decide and I decided to give him some space.
He called me four days later.
I don't remember the conversation.
When were you drunk?
But he said he'd call me back.
That was four months ago.
Clearly he doesn't give a shit.
I get that,
but I cannot understand how we could be so much in my life and then just never
fucking talk to me again.
The fuck dude.
The fuck you sound cool as hell.
By the way.
The more,
the more immediate problem is that in a few weeks a mutual friend is having a
birthday party and dude is going to because it's going to be there.
What the fuck do I do,
Bill?
How do I face him?
Do I confront him?
Do I ignore him a bugging out?
Please help me.
Thank you in any advice in the law and he has got a golf.
I wish she was here this week.
Um,
okay.
All right.
Here's the deal.
This isn't about him.
This is about you.
All right?
Be honest with yourself.
Be kind of setting.
You knew what this guy was.
You knew who he was.
All right,
but he just had that fucking thing.
All right?
You just had that fucking charisma or whatever and two year,
two years into it,
you're drunk.
He started and you went through it,
the whatever,
you know,
he got freaked out and confirm what you knew all the time and he fucking left.
All right.
That'd be honest with me.
Do you want to fight that fight?
Okay.
Before you met this guy and you fantasize about the man you are going to marry,
was this how it was going to play out?
Was this,
does this something that you want to fucking deal with?
You realize you're going to have to like trying to bring this fucking fish in
the amount of heartache,
the amount of extra curricular activities and all that fucking shit that comes
along with a guy like this?
Well,
why would you do that?
Why would you do that to yourself?
You don't need this shit.
All right.
Okay.
The problem is is you're,
you're trying to like,
you're trying to,
okay.
Like figure out the sanity in somebody insane behavior.
Okay.
You knew what he was and then he confirmed it and now you're like,
does he mean this is exactly,
how could he just do that?
Because he's a fucking load of 10 he's a load of tech.
Who knows?
Because his dad ran around on his mom because his mom took off on his dad.
Who the fuck knows because it his bullshit,
his giant truck load of fucking bullshit.
Okay.
That he is still not even begun to deal with,
which is why he's behaving like that around you.
You don't fucking need that Jesus Christ.
All the guys in the fucking world go to the party and have a good time.
Yeah,
just tell him just,
you know,
if you see him,
just say what's up.
No need to be weird.
Okay.
Over whatever we
had.
We had a good time.
It's fucking over.
I knew you were nuts.
Now you confirmed it.
All right.
Stop fucking looking at me like you've seen a gold like I,
I would just go there and have a good time.
I wouldn't ignore him.
I wouldn't confront him.
I would just say hello and then I would go on.
What's happening.
If he wants to talk,
talk to him.
If he doesn't,
just go on with having a good time.
If you bump into them against,
say hello again,
but don't let that fucking guy ruin your good time.
Alright.
And quit fucking wasted mental time trying to figure out his bullshit.
He's not worth it.
Fuck up.
All right.
There you go.
Fuck them.
Hey,
who knows?
You might meet Mr Right at that place.
Ooh,
the everlasting love.
A documentary suggestion.
A dear Billy boo.
If you haven't seen the documentary on Netflix about the Ukraine revolution,
you should definitely check it out.
I would love to see that.
Um,
it's called winter on fire.
Yeah,
that sounds like a really bad 80 song.
Okay.
Where do you,
oh,
is that cell saying almost far?
I can find some fucking Russians.
I don't like biting me a Putin.
I'm sorry.
In the immortal words of Ron Burgundy.
Wow.
That escalated quickly.
My singing more the,
uh,
the documentary,
it starts with some activists deciding to congregate in one place,
which started as an event sent out on Facebook and ended up replacing their
president.
Okay.
Every time I reached you like this,
like I am amazed at the human spirit and also feel so fucking lucky that I
haven't had to experience that in a country,
you know?
Okay.
I then the country I live in,
we haven't gone through some shit like that.
Hopefully it will never fucking happen because I don't think I could stomach it.
You know,
hearing people running up and down the street and you'd just sit in there in the
house
who was in charge.
Um,
the idea is so foreign to us and I think most people don't understand just how
crazy it is.
Yeah.
I mean I don't,
I'm trying to wrap my head around it,
but you are really good at seeing crazy shit.
No one notices that is right under our noses.
So I think you'll be floored by this.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
What?
Thank you for the,
uh,
the recommendation.
I will definitely try to,
uh,
check that out as soon as I can.
Is that all this shit?
Is that all the fucking,
okay.
What am I up to here?
58 minutes and 56 seconds,
I think.
I could bullshit for another minute and call this a God damn day.
Was it something else that I had to talk about here on the podcast?
Um,
oh yeah.
I decided,
uh,
I ran into a buddy of mine and he told me his new year's new year's resolution
was,
he wasn't going to argue with his wife this year and he's made it all the way to
February.
I was like,
you know what,
that's a really cool resolution and I haven't any this year.
So,
um,
I'm not giving up arguing with my wife,
uh,
for two reasons.
One,
it would destroy my act into I'm a selfish son of a bitch.
Um,
I've lost,
I have no control over my fucking emotions.
I don't,
it's shameful,
but I don't.
Um,
so I decided instead,
I'm going to,
I'm trying to get back into learning French.
Uh,
I feel like as I'm approaching,
you know,
the mid century mark here,
if I don't fucking do it now,
I'm going to be fucked.
I'm never going to learn how to do it.
Um,
so I'm fucking,
I'm back into it.
I'm do a lingo.
I've done it three days in a fucking row.
And the only reason why I'm announcing it to you guys is because if you don't
hear me talking about it,
please break my balls to say that I fucking quit again.
I'm a loser.
And all that type of Shell,
that wonderful positive shit that you guys can say anonymously,
anonymously on the Internet.
Um
Oh,
by the way,
you know,
you know it's funny in this fucking business,
like they never tell the performer shit.
Right?
So I'm on stage this weekend.
I got to ask you if there's any doctors out there.
I'm fucking onstage and I'm doing my act.
I don't even know what night it was.
It might've been the first show last night
and the whole time I'm doing my act,
everything I fucking say
some guy in the crowd is just like repeating it or commenting on it.
You know what I mean?
Like not like cackling.
It's more like,
like black church,
like call and response.
I was like,
yeah,
you know,
I was walking down the street the other day and he says,
oh yeah,
well I mean down the street,
you know,
doing that shit the whole fucking time.
But he's not so loud that the rest of the crowd can hear it.
Some hope.
And if I just ignore him,
he's going to stop and he doesn't.
And finally after like a half an hour,
I was like,
dude,
when you shut the fuck up,
you don't have to fucking comment on everything.
Is that all right?
All right.
He's just doing that shit,
but I love you.
It's take saying shit like that and you know I was trashing them and all that
shit.
So afterwards I ended up meeting him after the show and he ended up telling me
that he had Tourette's and then somebody on the show goes,
yeah,
he had Tourette's.
We didn't know if he should throw them out.
It's like,
why don't you fucking tell me that before I make a fucking ass out of myself?
I felt terrible.
But here's my question,
is that a former Tourette's at that Tourette's is either you're cursing your
brains out or you make weird noises or yet you do some sort of physical tick.
I didn't know that you fucking,
all of a sudden we're doing that,
you know,
I'm in a Baptist church,
except doing it in a way that eggs on the fucking speaker,
it actually annoys the shit out of it.
Well,
maybe that's my temperament.
I have no idea.
Um,
that's my question for somebody out there in the medical field,
is that a,
a form of Tourette's or was he just trying to make me feel bad?
I'm literally yawning here like a fucking idiot.
Um,
all right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Oh,
Biz Billy.
No booze bag is back on the fucking wagon again.
Um,
I got to tell you,
as much as I fucking go up and down with that shit,
at least I do nip it in the bud.
You know,
I,
uh,
I just drank too much.
Was it Friday night?
Woke up fucking hung over.
Tired as shit.
I was just like,
what the fuck am I doing to myself is stupid.
And then I watched black mask and I was watching them drinking Budweisers in
1970s pull tab cans.
And I was like,
God,
I miss that.
I miss it already.
All right.
That's a podcast for this week.
Sorry.
Uh,
it was so late.
Um,
if you'd like to contributed to this podcast,
as I tell you that it's late to,
anytime you go to Amazon,
just go through the podcast page,
um,
not the podcast page,
my website,
click on the merge page.
You Click on the Amazon link and a,
I get credit for driving people there and I give 10% of that shit to the Saint
Jude until you tell me that that one's a scam to everyone that I give to you
guys eventually end up telling me that.
But I think this is a good one.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you on Thursday.